four american college students a degree
often comes with something that lasts
long after graduation
it's the sometimes massive debt
accumulated to pay tuition and other
expenses last year student debt in the
u.s. topped 1.5 trillion dollars and the
average student will around $22,000 by
the time they graduate but some schools
are managing to buck the trend including
one pioneering college in Kentucky that
incredible as it sounds
hasn't charged a dime of tuition in over
a hundred and twenty years did you ever
think you could afford college nope I
thought whatever price to go to college
would be something impossible for me to
pay the impossible is now reality for
Dave Bell the computer science major
graduates from college and Meg the first
in his family to do so and it didn't
cost him a cent when I first came here I
was wondering when's the school gonna go
bankrupt how is it still functioning did
it seem too good to be true yeah it
seemed like I'd have to pay something
back at some point but he doesn't bail
and all 16 hundred other students at
Kentucky's Berea College just outside of
Lexington get a free ride as long as
they work for it the school is one of
eight federally designated colleges that
require resident students to get a
part-time job
on or off campus I'm a teaching
assistant my first job was in Dining
Services as like a food worker but now I
help teachers with grading and so I'm a
tutor in and outside of class did you
Crafton eight students run everything
from the admissions office you can take
this sack to the historic Inn on campus
they even maintain the college grounds
students here are mostly from central
and southern Appalachia and all of
Kentucky their families are in an
average of $29,000 a year well below the
national median household income
what's your unofficial motto ask me
about the best education money can't buy
Boreas president lao rule off' says
that's largely thanks to the school's
endowment which covers 75% of its budget
the federal pell program which provides
need-based grants to low-income students
and fund raising provide the rest there
are schools which have equal resources
to hours on a per student basis I think
we could be a model for what we call
affordability and access over the last
decade private university tuition and
fees have shot up by 26 percent to about
$35,000 a year but due to an increase in
grants and tax savings the actual net
cost is lower still lower income
families have felt the pinch because of
rising inequality and stagnant wages
since the recession students are coming
from families with higher incomes simply
can't find a seat within our student
body
Luke Hudson graduated from Berea with a
business degree in 2002 now he's the
director of admissions our holistic
review really tries to determine who has
that academic readiness who has the grit
who's a fit for the institution because
Bri is not for everybody the idea of
asking students to be full-time academic
scholars on top of full-time work that's
purely embedded into the experience it
takes a student who wants to manage that
well to really persist since its
founding in 1855 Berea has persisted in
civil rights as well admitting
african-americans and women at the
insistence of its founder abolitionist
minister John Gregg fee all that changed
in 1904 when Kentucky outlawed
integrated schools Berea was forced to
create a separate Institute for
minorities but in 1950 Kentucky ended
segregation four years before the US
Supreme Court Rule
the practice unconstitutional how on
earth did you hear about this school
actually I googled that and Berea has
opened the doors to international
applicants as well like Alexandra
Vuitton osika of Macedonia
this was definitely a life-changing
thing for somebody from small country in
Eastern Europe to be giving a chance to
come here like I got to have some crazy
good internships I got to go study
abroad Salim bin Saud is from Tunisia I
will never forget like the gift Berea
has given me and I will be giving back
in all ways and sorts in the future
moving forward Dave Bell says he's
inspired by Boreas mission you've gotten
a free education what does that mean to
you
well for one that's a hundred thousand
dollar investment in my future after
four years that means a lot when I'm
about to graduate with no debt you know
and also that further promotes me into
wanting to give back to the community
which is why I'll be trying to go to
grad school and become a teacher myself
you really get the sense from these
students that they have that sort of
like service and give back in them in
their soul I have to note that one of
the famous graduates of Berea is the
father of black history
Carter G Woodson was the last graduate
before they cut off the integrated
schooling back in 1904 what a load off
first and to graduate debt-free I mean
yeah I was gonna say it's priceless but
that does not seem right yeah it really
is so important it really was starting
in a hole like that